What's up everyone! We are going to look at a second very important topic in economics. This is supply or when firms have the willingness and ability to sell a product.
Let's jump into it.
We have a supply schedule on the left and we are selling pizzas. You'll notice we have two variables, price and quantity supplied.
Also at the price decreases from $25 all the way down to $5 the quantity supplied also decreases from 40,000 to 0.
This is what we call the law of supply, that is there is an direct relationship between the price of a good and the quantity supplied of that good, ceteris paribus.
This is an important concept to firms as it shows there is a price that is too low for them to sell.
Of course they can't charge the maximum price as they may not get that many buyers.
Let's go ahead and sketch in these numbers in our graph to the right.
We're going to first label vertical axis was price.
And the horizontal axis with quantity supplied.
Now let's put in the numbers.
And let's put in some dots.
And we'll connect those dots.
And there you have a supply curve. This curve shows the pairing of the individual prices and their respective quantities.
As we move down along the supply curve you'll notice
price falls, and the quantity supplied also falls.
As we move up along the supply curve the price rises as does the quantity supplied. This again shows the willingness of those producers to sell more at those higher prices.
Basically any time the price of a good changes
we get a change in quantity supplied so to change the quantity supplied, this is important, we have to have a change
price.
But what happens if something other than
price of the good changes? Suppose more firms enter the market. This causes a complete change in the supply curve. The same can be said if firms leave as well. In each case the supply curve will shift to the right
as an increase in supply.
Or, it will shift to the left
as a decrease in
supply.
In this next table we have a new quantity, one that changed because of some factor other than price change.
If firms enter the market then at price more firms are willing to sell more pizzas. This shift the supply curve to the left,
to the right.
However if firms left the market than the supply curve shifts to the left as there are not enough firms to sell the same amount of pizza as before at the same price. Let's relabel our graph. P for
price.
Q for quantity.
Our supply curve is upward sloping and we will have an increase in our supply curve,
so we will shift it to the right.
And a decrease in our supply curve so we will shift it to the left.
There are quite a few determinants of supply. We've already mentioned one and that is a change in the number firms in the market.
We saw that an increase in firms leads to an increase in supply.
And a decrease in firms leads to a decrease in supply.
Our next determine is a change in technology.
where technology is bringing the factors of production, like capital and labor, together to make production more efficient.
Suppose a new technological process is introduced to make pizza faster.
This will increase the supply curve.
If we were first that technology then we would have a decrease in the supply curve.
What happens if the price of labor, that is wages and salaries, rise?
This increases the cost of production for a firm.
Therefore they see a rising cost but maybe no rise in revenue.
Firms then don't want to produce as much so we can see any increase in input prices causes a decrease in supply.
The opposite is true.
If labor costs were to fall then we would see the supply curve increase. Let's take a here just to clean this graph up.
Okay.
People like to plan for the future and so do firms. Firms like to know how the price of their product will change. They want to know if it will increase or if it will decrease.
If our p;izza makers expect prices to rise in the future
they'll be less likely to sell more pizzas today. so the supply will decrease.
However is our pizza makers expect prices in the future to fall then they're more likely to sell pizzas today to capture that price.
So we will see am increase in the supply curve or a shift to the right.
Our last determinant deals with changes in taxes and subsidies.
Firms often have taxes levied on their products from state and local governments. If a firm has to pay the tax then it has an added cost.
Now, they don't want to produce as much because of this higher cost of production. So the supply curve will decrease as a result.
If those governments remove those taxes then firm costs decrease and the supply curve
increases.
Subsidies are like a benefit to production in that they lower the cost of production.
If the government awards firms a subsidy to our pizza makers
then they are able to produce more, thus increasing the supply curve.
However if the government takes the pizza subsidy away from our firms then our supply curve
decreases.
You should have noticed that each of these determines the price of pizza never changed it was some other factor--the determinants--
that cause a change in the supply for
pizza.
This is important to note the distinction between a change in the quantity supplied, which is a movement along the supply curve, and is caused by a change in the price of a good versus a change in supply which is a shift of the entire supply curve either as an increase which is a shift to the right or a decrease which is a shift to the left. And this is caused by those determinants of supply.
Alright that's it. We'll see you in the next video.